rob handlery hey mike what's going on
oh not much just uh you know about to
play one of my favorite games of all
time
psychonauts
titanfall 2. yeah we're here with
titanfall 2 the new dlc is out today as
long as well as a patch right
yeah this is uh one of the bigger
updates free updates for the game um
colony reborn colony reborn new map two
new prime titans which you have to buy
and i will because i'm
willing to give money
of my own for this game and uh yeah a
bunch of new other features yeah um
we're gonna go through it all
uh let's yeah let's uh of course
everybody in the twitch and youtube
chats i have that up i'll be monitoring
that if you wanna converse with me tell
rob
to stop using that shotgun that he
always uses i will be here to relay
those messages uh cool let's get into it
i am excited to get into this uh i can
yeah before we uh i mean you can tinker
around but i can uh kind of summarize it
quick before we jump in sure do you want
to turn down the gameplay yeah just tab
before i blow someone's eardrum thanks
uh so
comedy reborn update
i launched today ps4 xbox one pc
uh and then we have a full patch notice
as well but it adds the new map well the
existing map from the first titanfall
colony but it brings us to titanfall 2.
there's a new weapon the r101 we're
looking at it that is it right there
that's the r101 that's exactly it it
looks kind of similar to the r201 yeah
it's rocking
what uh
look at the stats what's different it's
not as powerful what is the i mean i'm
not seeing any numbers well you got to
let it there you go look go back to the
201 and pause for a second it's kind of
like load
alright try that now yeah now go down to
that and now let this
no i mean look i go down to hemlock
i guess
aesthetics i don't know
all right okay all right okay
um cool but of course this is also free
there are new paid items such as two new
prime titans
uh and then there's 20 each of new camos
banners and patches uh you did you buy
the two new prime titans i bought one
but i'm guessing sorry your favorite is
the one that i know on the flip i wanted
to show this purchase
because
if you do know i'm sure you do that i
love northstar
a lot and look at that it's pretty good
my god
yeah it's really good we're buying it
you wanna move over this way a little
more sure i'll get closer cool all right
well we will jump in i believe you there
should be an easy option to uh
you know play colony right yeah yeah uh
typically they have a playlist devoted
to the new stuff okay uh so we're doing
it we're doing it and then the new
execution as well curb check which looks
pretty awesome that's right fan of these
yeah and those have been pretty neat
because they all kind of reflect the uh
pilot um
abilities right like the triple punch
from uh
stem was it last week or last update was
right that was very much like ipman yeah
um
so these are just oh you just get so now
they have so there's a whole new menu
here for the store 25
yeah so that's everything right so 20
new camo that's all the camo the primes
um
patches i mean who cares about like
banners though really yeah um just want
that hot north star paint so like look
at here here's new uh
art for north star
i believe yeah definitely that's cool
looking
uh someone just said game spot why are
you closing stores
uh we're game spot
gosh stop that's real great that's
that's threatening what do you think
um
that one's sick that looks like a reaper
from overwatch i'm getting it
i i
this is this is my
this is my life i buy things for this
game because i love it so much
how much uh
cumulative
we don't have money we don't have to
talk about that above well okay not even
counting the game i've i've purchased
i've essentially purchased everything so
far okay um more than a hundred dollars
or is that even i don't think it's
possible no 25 25 i mean that's a whole
bundle so cool um there's camo
if you guys hang tight that's from the
angel city colony so this is cool again
i haven't seen any of this so this is
what i like better opposed to these like
these are more intense and i think a
little excessive as far as camo goes but
like i you know i like the more the
simplistic stuff so this is kind of neat
looking
um
that's cool all right well let's just uh
get into it i just want to see more
calling
okay yeah this is banners and stuff
these are kind of neat but
who cares about that let's play oh cool
one more thing yeah once we jump into a
game i'll kind of okay patch notes
there's changes yeah yeah
kind of boring kind of somewhere
yeah so if people in the chat haven't
figured it out yet this is rob's
favorite titan
uh my boy scorch i think got a little
bit of a nerf i gotta make sure they
didn't touch him too much
because if they did then we're gonna
have a problem
yeah
all right let's leave at that what are
we doing i'm sorry i'm i can get lost in
here forever yeah colony colony 24 7.
with double experience oh sync
might be excuse to jump back in
a lot of games to play
ice cream
says yasen
stop talk stop talking start playing all
right i agree i agree i apologize
specifically you no
okay cool
yeah hopefully we can get into a match
here i'm not seeing many
numbers
flying so
we'll see read off some patch notes oh
nevermind all right here we go colony so
um also worth noting is that like the
last um update we did there's a new
execution as we said what's it called
again
something shot
the new one the new one yeah curb stomp
charge
um hold on a second
curb check
curb check sorry
um we'll have to check and see all right
we're getting into it
yeah cause uh the last one was dependent
on you having a certain amount of kills
with the previous updates execution i
wonder if that's the same thing did you
check yeah yeah i'll have to check after
this
um
so i switched my threat optics out
there's no there's no reason to have it
in this uh mode obviously
okay it's on uh how do you mean
well threat optics are great for hunting
pilots but this is last time standing so
oh gotcha i didn't realize you're okay
so i switched to uh
pretty obvious where the titans are
right
for the most part yeah
screw that shot
i think north star is a titan i've used
the least
look at that
yeah
you're uh what are you uh scorch man
scorch uh and then i've been using a
ronin scorching road
all right
oh we got a pilot flying around
he's rocking the new skin
uh oh oh that's right he's doomed
something else we gotta do is show off
that new execution associated with the
skin oh north stars
oh he's he's hit
see if i can do it
yes yes yes yes yes yes
oh that's fun
missile faces him that was awesome
um another thing i'm probably going to
change here is
oh yeah i like the extra dash
the extra dash is my favorite when it's
used without ronin right the uh the
weaker titans yeah
uh ronin no start north star are a good
one
so we'll see if i can get one of these
batteries and prolong my lifespan here
risque let's do it
oh yeah new weapon
the 101 r101
it was interesting that it didn't have
any base stats different than the 201. i
wonder if it's just
oh man
this titan the titan skin of norse
reminds me of something like
blue and yellow no just the the the look
of it like the um
the armor covering
oh
yeah yep yep yep yep
oh damn
oh
pilot locking where are you he was the
guy ejected huh
whoops
behind us pilot
landing shots
where are you going
yeah look at that grin
oh baby it's really good
i can run through the patch notes quick
uh yeah
ones uh all right so
um
damage for the thunderbolt increase
uh
pulses fire to faster rate
not not a whole lot no nothing
the holo pilots now actually display the
name of the owner so that i guess it
fakes you out a little more if you're
not on the lookout oh interesting um
also subtle audio key was added
oh amped wall can now be destroyed
rather than just have to wait it out
oh okay yeah that was um people kind of
have been uh the a wall right
uh or just amp i think it's a wall
i just said the amp bar right here
yeah um you know people say people have
been really
not exploiting but uh using that a lot
only because uh oh man i should have
done this
it's just like you just can like get
that corner
oh christ bad move where are you come
here
like you know you get like a um a
devotion with an amp wall like oh my god
whoa a little bit of lag
uh henderson herrera we just if you're
just joining we did just use northstar's
prime execution try it again i'm sure
um
also
damaging titans
does not
add as much to your core meter
and then scorch
increase base duration of thermal shield
reduce the increased duration reduce the
increased duration of inferno shield kit
so the total duration is the same
uh nothing else
major really that's kind of it
yeah the rest is just minor bugs that
people are noticing
and as always various oh i'm getting lag
cool
so like we said nothing major
it's all time here
oh i saw your teammate's name in the
background i thought he was alive
but i guess he was a pilot
should i use legion
sure do you have the prime for that yep
i'm not very good with legion
legion is
good when you can i mean they're all
good
start mastering them but
[Music]
it's just yeah the the the predictive
the predictability factor of like trying
to you know do that switch right the
long and short range oh crap here we go
like right now
yeah it takes time
yeah suck it
who else do you like you like ronin
scores right those are your kind score's
my main i'd say ronin is close second uh
very different play styles i think maybe
that's why i gravitate toward the poles
uh
but i like a lot of people i like tone
as well and i actually think i'm
better with tone than i am ronin but
tone i think is a little more easier to
use
but
yeah
i appreciate tone i barely use legion or
north star
uh who am i forgetting ion
ion i was uh yeah ions good i think i
think the reason which is weird because
the reason i stayed away from scorch and
ion when you and i first went down the
review event for this game last year was
that those were the two in the uh the
alpha and the beta and one trap new
people but then i was like wow i
actually really like scorch and uh
ionics haven't gone back to although ion
is really interesting because all the
abilities feed into that one central
like ammo dump laser
whatever it is kind of gauge right which
i like because you're kind of
gauging which move is worth doing
so
i didn't kill that guy i'm risking here
here
come here
oh there's pilot right to my uh right
where are you
oh yeah for those joining this is colony
the new map uh
it's new for titanfall 2 but it's remade
from titanfall 1 and we're playing last
titan standing because it's the uh
colony 24 7 playlist this is the mode it
put us in do you like last time standing
rock
i do i don't play it enough um
i
i just like the trade-off of on foot
with titans right like um
i really do like moving around and wall
running and chaining those and stuff um
but it's you know it's it's a nice
change-up just like you know it's much
more tactical
it reminds me more of like a hero
shooter because you're paying much more
you're being more cautious you only have
one life and you're
i don't know
you're paying much more attention to
which titans coming at you and what the
match ups are and how you can help your
teammate out and it's 6v6 it's not
you know there aren't
grunts running around totally yeah you
get to kind of like hone in your titan
skills right opposed to just feeling
completely overpowered and punching
pilots left and right yeah let's see
what um
we got here as far as uh execution
what are our
requirements here curb check
oh it just comes with it so there you go
so this is the grappling hook one right
right
what's left then you got stem
phase dash
i don't know maybe like
amped shield or something
yeah like what could you throw a shield
inside someone's body
like i don't know what
what an amped shield uh execution could
look like
uh yeah i mean i suppose throw it under
them and just splits them in half
yeah
that'd be pretty sick actually
does this weapon have any unique
no
weird i wonder um
that seems odd that that gun um oh here
we go exact opposite um it seems odd
that the gun um doesn't have any notable
differences
yeah i mean i guess it's got a scope on
it
good luck but i mean you can get a scope
you can change scopes later on when you
upgrade any weapon right
yeah yeah exactly
oh
shucks rats
this is still colony right yeah okay
i want to ask you what you think about
it but you haven't really played
too much uh pilot yeah i think this was
the second map in
well because angel city was from
the first one too in the last update
that's what they added right they've
been adding the old ones and i think
that's because you know a lot if there's
one major complaint you hear about this
game is that people aren't really that
happy with the map design
um and appreciate the first game more so
that's what you're seeing a lot more of
these
nice move
these uh
maps from the first game pretty cool
respawned uh
acknowledge it you know or just like you
know
not even acknowledge it i guess just
like deliver what people want
but
top hat that would be him
we don't need him
uh yeah brandon john in the youtube chat
colony yeah
colony reborn dlc is free the map and
titan primes are not right that's those
are cosmetics certain cosmetics and oh
here we go
here's the new assassination right here
nope never mind that's it no that was it
uh
here's the new assassination
don't stop nevermind
fairy anna
great
you know it's interesting because
remember last time how many executions
we had to do like like 10 10
but the previous one was 50. yeah now i
think they probably got feedback they
realized that chain reaction was not a
good well and i think the other well it
takes a while right it's not easy but
also
you know you like to think that
challenges in this game are still going
to have some kind of benefit to your
team but execution yeah running into the
middle of oh what no that was lag that's
not my fault
is there ping low
uh yeah you know i mean like like the
first one that they had
my god it was 50 executions no one liked
me that was the the one where you warp
into them with yeah yeah inner pieces
i don't know what do you think of the
three are your favorite i think the
inner pieces i don't know i really liked
the last the last one we did triple
punch yeah
they've all been really fantastic
the centerpiece is the most uh like
aggressive
yeah yeah
all right we're getting major if you see
that happen to your friend okay
yeah right
oh this is not my fault okay
well i thought you meant that you were
losing oh
oh you're not we're not losing we're
running by quite a decent amount you
know we're losing
internet
somehow
feel it
god see damn that guy's been up there a
while
sniping
god damn it
you are winning this battle keep
fighting pilot sorry i wonder if um
i wonder
it's weird i
feel it's like did the was the wingman
elite maybe we'll look and see if like
that was just cosmetic well that was
definitely different it was i think it
had
less rounds and a clip uh
i'm fairly certain it was different
less powerful but higher fire rate maybe
i just wonder if the ui wasn't loading
for this or something
that's what i'm thinking
is like it's just a little
hitch a little hiccup
oh man this guy's everywhere
i want this execution yeah
i want it mike where are you
do i like the new map
yeah i do i'm liking it so far
i think it's a nice mix
of like indoor and
and
um you know i i
i mean people in the chat can like agree
or disagree but i feel like one of the
reason for the complaints on the maps is
like
in the newer ones a lot of them have
like
wall running routes more or less opposed
to like create your own kind of
wow look at all these guys
it's it definitely felt more like there
were lanes to the map right like you
were kind of repeating the same motions
the same lanes exactly yeah opposed to
like you know uh having the more
sporadic like in the moment moves
oh
that's something saw me
nope i want to go in there
great
this map looks pretty good yeah
definitely
do you prefer the new maps or have you
been like in angel city and i mean it's
kind of early to tell i i really like
angel city yeah and i and i'm so far i'm
liking this this is in the same vein
just watching you play seems more free
form than the other ones exactly kind of
if you
i don't know i felt like if i started
getting shot i would keep running
forward to get
away to the other side of the map
whereas this kind of turn on a dime and
then
and that's not the case with all the
titanfall 2 maps but a lot of them felt
like they were more geared toward
outdoor titan heavy combat
yeah totally
these guys like to snipe oh
all right let's see if i can get an
execution because i really want to see
it
oh
he saw me ah
faryana great again
uh
ix queen
uh queen sophie on youtube was asking
if the new xbox one dashboard is good
did you try it yet it came out yesterday
oh no
i have not gotten the chance i kind of
want to check that out later yeah
definitely
hopefully it's a huge improvement
oh
shoot
yeah
i don't i okay great
that guy looked like he was get
cause he's posing for a selfie like
zelda
what do you know what's different about
the uh xbox one i don't know actually i
might check it out now it's kind of a
mountain but
uh
you're liking this map yeah andrew lopez
was asking is the map good um i'm liking
it for sure
i mean as you mentioned like there's a
lot more like
frenetic movement and stuff
um
which is very much in the titanfall vein
right like that's good
um
you know i tell you what i just realized
this would be a prime map for the eva
shotgun my fave yeah i was kind of
waiting for you to go back to that i'm
surprised i haven't
i forgot how much i like the um
i always forget the name because numbers
are the r2 or this is the what again the
new one
r2 101 r101 201 is the titanfall 2
starting assault rifle right
right
well now i got a new scope on it i think
nope that perk and yeah yeah trail mix
on youtube said two words grapple
execution we're trying trying
i'm trying
you're doing great mike thanks
probably go to what like three-ish today
yeah you gotta get out here
uh that's fine kind of but i guess i'm
open to whatever
um yeah we'll see how it goes
once we see what this
all has to offer
i should have bought yeah so the new uh
just again the new xbox one dashboard is
a
new home screen uh
improved guide menu
beam streaming
huh
uh
back to that in a second someone asked
um
yeah the uh the new dlc nose art on
prime titans yeah that was kind of the
bummer about getting a private titan is
that all you couldn't use any nose art
at all but that they fixed that so all
nose art works for any titans
can i go back to the north star
no that makes sense
i do like uh oh you know what
we should see the execution on uh legion
it's not as cool
i like his uh the the regular uh legion
one i think he like shoves it
doesn't he lift them up yeah barrel and
then just like shred them
yeah exactly
north star oh look at this guy coming
around town
yeah okay let's go
hi
yeah get him yeah get him
get him awesome a few legions right
there okay
sound like i said lesions
oh crap this happens oh yeah you have a
legion on your back
this is why north star like out in the
open and you're doing that move ah
that's risky man
that's the thing about northstar's core
ability is i
you got to resist the urge to use it
uh i have some kind of cover yeah
anything but like just last resort it's
like one on one i guess but like
especially in this mode
she
she she's the glass cannon of the group
or one of them
i shouldn't use it then
hi
i messed that up
i mess that up big
you're no good here oh [ __ ] chad
where's that from you're no good get out
of here i have no clue what i'm talking
about where's that from i just may be
attracted thought it sounded funny
you're no good here get out of here ah
he's gotta like get out of there
get out of the way he's like gotta he's
gotta get out of the battle you're no
good here get out of here
i don't know this is dumb sorry
obscure pop culture references just
sometimes go over my head
not that i can talk i do them all the
time
she rolling with uh some north oh we
should show the execution
great
you bet that shut up
i just love the
movement everything about north star is
hot
gotcha
oh
are they any game modes with this update
no they did not
uh not since that what was that gamer
they added with live fire was the last
one yeah yeah yeah
i wonder if uh i wonder if they have
that here oh movement on twitch what's
up
they're saying hi robin mike hi
look at this butthead
i was trying to predict it
what i like doing is this
oh i don't have thread optics that's
what's really cool about it
like that's what's fun is to experiment
like i was changing up north star i was
using um using
an extra electric smoke and then threat
optic so i could just like have that
sense of mask yeah and just peek through
and
pick off pilots and snipers
nope
no
christ
cripes
oh yeah
was there a battery there
risky i'm doing it
oh [ __ ] we
let's give him a little bit of that
i like the idea of what yeah the idea
was there blinding him a little bit you
know it doesn't do as much blind let's
see
yeah i remember someone saying that like
i just had you dialed in though
the uh
he you know would be better here
actually as a loadout would be using the
arc
grenade
because that straight up does blind
joshie boy says love north star oh my
god my bae
see this guy can do it probably not
there's no way uh
yeah
i mean what was the point of ejecting
there anyway he could have had like an
auto yeah he would have been cloak
yeah good point
oh there's no ping's eye there
oh that's a funny banner actually it was
like a titan doing like the god
to adam
oh yeah yeah michael uh sistine chapel
thank you
thank you michael
angelo
d'angelo
um hopefully we get some attrition or
something cool we got some guys
joining uh the
gamespot network of two
appreciate it
uh yeah we have let's see several
different game spot networks but this is
the one you use we have a lot a lot of
people in our group let's check giant
bombs as well i think that's the one
that's usually pretty popular check out
our network how many people we have here
12.
actually i was expecting to be much
lower
do join though
i i filter between the uh you're you
made the spot i made the gspt one
um by the way this is the third but i
forget this is the way to go i don't
know if you like mess around with
setting these active
like try to diverse uh as far as like a
span of a day you just like turn them on
and off and get that bonus
when the happy hour is going on yeah
all right another last titan standing
can we get
some
uh attrition or even
oh cool throw me into a two minute
round three
rut
so what's the what's the update again
it's oh yeah
colony reborn
um i'm sorry as far as like so two new
primes i guess
just think of other things we haven't
maybe shown off other than the hamilton
20 camos
if you're into that if you're into the
pilot camo sure
uh nose
paints
right us people were asking for north
star's nose paints cool you guys shot
them earlier but we can show those is it
just north star or is there two per
titan or something
there's four per titan four new ones uh
we could actually go through them all we
should probably do that because um
that's worth showing
so these are the new ones for north star
i like this grim
face of death that's nice
that would go nice with some black skin
but of course you gotta be generation 10
for that
oh yeah
i'm eight something
it takes a while i'm impressed to anyone
who's gone
i use northstar like
so much i have not gone there yet
nice
one two three
i got some someone flanking over here
yeah i'd like to see and i thought about
the other day like i want to see like if
there are any like
i don't know i'm sure there are pro
teams get on my way
like you know like what what's the
ultimate
last standing team you know what i mean
like how are you diversifying obviously
you want like
a tone
yeah i think tone fits pretty well into
any team
oh
nice shot
go
upstairs this is a risk
or was it
oh we're down
i gotta step my game up
it's just me great
one
if i pull this off
i'm gonna be a very happy person
oh that's why i got time though right i
gotta find these uh igniter i think the
titanfall one map with the shipwreck
was relic
i believe
or lagoon no i think it was relics
f
uh moomin on twitch was saying was the
campaign for titanfall 2 any good heard
it was okay
sorry say that again movement on twitch
was saying was the campaign any good in
titanfall 2. you heard it was okay
wait what i'm sorry say that again
movement on twitch said was the campaign
any good with this game titanfall oh
yeah okay uh yeah you're saying movement
no no uh it was fantastic yeah oh the
campaign's great it's like it's i mean
people were complaining short but i
think it's a really perfect length
like four and a half hours
a little more but i mean it's fun as
hell a few levels that still stand out
my memory after playing it last year
yeah uh there are some like
fantastic moments in that campaign um
like i mean i played it three times
um and that's kind of like the
the plus
of it being short enough and having that
like
pace of just change constantly changing
um
you just it's the time flies by and like
in the best possible way where you're
just like consistently like being thrown
to a different area
you're being limited um it's super
diverse and i just love that yeah um
yeah
i really wanna do the curb check we
gotta do that oh we can show skins for a
second
i know we'll do it real quick
uh i think we go to the store for that
this is all new here um
camo again i kinda like it's like you
know less
abrasive in my opinion because this is
all just like chaotic um
but
customization
let's see here this is from the previous
one
oh wait what
what is that called oh it's just these
four for each titan
that's weird i'm sorry what i'm sorry
let me explain
uh
as the last angel city pack had um
unique skins to each titan i'm only
seeing the same
six
for uh all these titans i guess they
didn't make unique ones
that can't be right i feel like we're
getting some hud things that are off
right
like why would i buy this
four dollar pack
for each titan if it's the same thing
you know what i mean just to have it for
your favorite titan yeah i guess
it's weird i haven't had a little weird
maybe there's the rest were like unique
before the dlc right exactly
interesting yeah so this is boar
fish death
flowers
um
yeah and then you got the two guys here
yeah jones just said you're breaking the
game
i'm breaking the game
in what way i don't know [ __ ] up the
ui
i am i am doing that
i yeah i feel like it's weird too
someone in the chat agrees i
like you know again the uh r
101
that's new what you wouldn't have the
same stats as they are 201 doesn't make
sense
doesn't make any
sense but maybe we won't get titan last
night and standing this time
or pilot's first pilots actually i'd
rather have that okay go great you could
just do a non-colony 24 7 match try to
get the execution the pilot execution
grapple hook show people that
yeah i agree what are we doing on time
20 minutes or so okay why don't
let's try to get the legion execution i
like those teeth
yeah
gremlin
how do you unlock curb check yeah that's
the new pilot execution um you don't
this time
you just have it at least for me i have
it yeah
yeah like the
angel city's most wanted had that you
had to get 50
executions to unlock uh the inner pieces
and then
uh
what was it live fire last night ten
right you needed ten with that so if you
didn't get the right at first you needed
sixty total with the new ones that's
right that's what was so such a stretch
maybe they change it with this just to
give it to people maybe they complained
about it
yeah because if you get behind the dlc
you're not playing constantly
gonna have a lot of catch up to do yep
one of my favorite things to do with
scorch is to just melt uh pilots with my
flame shield thermal shield yeah
or that that's or that satisfying yeah
uh let's do legion am i
if i have time
nope nope nope nope nope yes
actually i also want to do this
and we're missing a titan or a player so
that's
great great great start
someone else is also already out of
there titan without getting a battery i
would assume i would hope
you guys are screwed
e3
damn
i think a pilot went for that battery oh
he did
hello
christ
here's my boy
yeah
i hate your boy
oh auto titan
where'd he
yeah
go
damn
i want that execution
i don't even know what legion's new
execution is
oh rocks holy [ __ ] i engaged that shield
too early
and got a little too aggressive with
that
oh yeah
and built one gaming most titans
standing
i'm into it
yikes
yeah but you know what i mean like with
like last time standing like i'm really
interested to see like if there is a
successful
or like your ideal like team right
to see some cool moves oh there it is i
mean team competition and like hero
shooters is huge
you wonder if that translates to this
you know or like like an overwatch move
right and just have like all ronins yeah
five ronins just in your face
can't go well rico montero yeah scorch
is my my favorite titan as well
let's give a dash
like i don't know like
the ideal loadout for legion
all right i gotta focus on execution i
wanna see it
boost is kinda slow
igniter on youtube was saying prime
legion's execution is where he hits
titan's predator cannon kills with a
power shot
damn
yeah
all right matches that sounds insane
all anything matches really when
everybody knows what abilities are being
used against them
yeah i don't see a
yeah i mean i guess i got like just a
north star team what would that be like
be the most annoying team ever ever like
just five guys hanging out in the corner
yeah
the ocean
there what's your favorite weapon
favorite weapon pilot yeah uh i'd have
to see the
photo if it's the
it's got the brown the wooden stock uh
it's the assault rifle oh flat line the
flat line and the alternator the little
handheld smg yeah alternator a lot
molten air is awesome
i have another couple matches or a match
or two after this yeah
i'm uh
yeah as you said i wonder if we should
steer away from colony just try to grab
ah see that
grappling hook execution
absolutely
where are you going
what was the price of prime titans
joshie boy was asking they're i think
they're like five bucks yeah which is
pretty pretty steep it comes with uh the
paint and the execution or sorry the
body and the execution is that right
right the prime has its own ex
yeah the prime has its own execution
are you liking legion you said you don't
use them often
i'm liking them
um
there's just a lot to think about but
then again that goes with experience
yeah i mean
a lot for me to think about north star
but you've gotten much better use out of
her mm-hmm
yeah i really want to see this execution
pull it off here nope i should have done
on that guy i forgot no pressure
oh uh oh
hopefully someone comes to help you out
oh damn damn
that was risky
meanwhile
good
good just want this to end
all right here's what i say we do let's
give colony one more shot see if we get
some attrition in here maybe uh the
playlist will say what modes are
are in it because it feels odd that
we've been
just getting last time standing yeah go
for at least another 10 minutes um no
but like if i don't get anything not
um last uh titan standing
that makes sense okay if i get last time
standing i'm just gonna find someone
else all right let's um
let's see here
like doesn't i guess it doesn't give you
yeah all right let's give him a shot
like that feels
i find that very hard to believe that
there's only nose art
like you know
like what
like it just feels odd to buy like those
six yeah like if it's so six i should be
able to put them on on anything
um
yeah
please
was it last time standard nc
sounds it i don't hear you on a drop
ship oh [ __ ] never mind cool
uh what is this
namaste
um
what is this
go go go she didn't say anything
focus
okay cool maybe get a grappling hook
execution you got i do have an equip
still right oh yeah
uh yeah
legit man he got both here let's double
check yes
oh
come on
yes
yeah
did you do anything else after you pull
them to the ground it kind of got
blocked by a box in there
uh punch him or anything
i think it kicks him oh kurt well it's a
curve stop right or something maybe
that's what the finisher is
see if we can do it again
that's that guy in here
this game is so good he's dude this is
the movement man i'm so glad we're not
doing last time standing right now
oh something in there like as good as
the movement is i still want you to get
back into titan then when you start
playing with the titan as good as that
is i still wanted you to start playing
as a pilot again and that's the beauty
of the pace right of each match is that
like you know you get 10 minutes or so
or less than that of this and then oh
man there are a lot of guys around
you're just really going for those
executions aren't you i am i want to see
it again
i wish i had camo
ah christ i'm so in the open
oh there's a guy i i'm such a jerk
don't move
stay still
damn it you have the angle after the
head
oh big dick 92
man they really filtered that username
it's pretty tough to get around the the
sensors these days
just can't always delete one letter and
you're fine this is on top the highest
point in the game to shoot people i mean
to be fair he's earning the net yeah it
sure is
look at these grapples sons of bees
oh
all right i gotta step it up
i am seeing or feeling a lot of lag [ __ ]
check comes with the update yes taylor
jorgensen on youtube
you do not have to unlock it on like
last time all right
unless you think like it had anything to
do with the number of kills with that
first execution because it's impossible
pretty sure it's it's at the very least
it's easier to get than it was uh for
uh
the stim one whatever that was the
triple punch one sure i don't i i
yeah i don't think so
my mind is in execution right now
oh
oh nice one
oh no it's a titan
so by engaging that emergency battery
pack i just threw a nade instead of
taking his battery out
foreign
they're all like yo turklebango that
doing their teams trying to assassinate
us so
keep an eye out
give it to me all right
next goal
execution with legion
all right we've got some competition
here
oh you know what i saw north star he
sees me
nice drop
[ __ ]
oh yeah
not this [ __ ]
nice
i knew it
say i saw his mind there and i saw it i
don't know
heather yeah
just sweeping this execution right here
jesus
damn that guy got lucky oh he dropped
it's high and he lured me into it good
move
i think he was pretty good if not he got
lucky
oh
nope
i thought it's not going there
that's like one of the standard ones
yeah
there's john wickson like seven times
christ
kind of hard survivor close match
very close to me right
so what's the difference between
hardcover and amp shield again hard
carver is just oh [ __ ] covers like the
pilot oh it amps your stuff and his
cover oh okay never mind
damn
nope
yeah yeah oh it's a big dick
damn he's done oh he got it
oh there he is here's big dick
oh he's on you never mind
i love that they just become a mist
i don't think that would happen oh oh oh
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yep yep
i'm punching i'm punching
detonated oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay
i i was like stuck in like zoom
sorry guys
sorry everyone
yeah yeah got him oh just you hear the
neck crunching noise it makes when he
hits the ground yeah that's pretty
gruesome
oh
all right okay
q man
wow this is still a close game huh
yeah the whole time oh you guys pulled
ahead you're just down by like 100.
what
dude uh uh i'm surprised that let you
drop it there uh oh
is that happening before are you stuck
you're totally stuck
oh my god look at that
that is the first time i've ever seen
that happen in this game no talk about
it talk about a bug
yeah they're usually really good about
wow
keeping those zones free of titans right
wow oh okay i can boost out of it okay
sweet but people but i'm legion i put a
boost on me yeah you got lucky uh people
in the chat were saying there it has
been a little buggy i don't know if
that's it must be the update right this
game's usually pretty solid
yeah sure um i mean maybe it's good all
this stuff's still rolling out yeah and
you know
people are gonna flock to this
please let me get you
doing the move
they scold me oh i'm so bad at legion
how does the amp shield get destroyed i
think you could just punch it and
i would think you could punch it i mean
assuming it has like hit points now that
they did the update you can just try it
now
or yeah the amp shield now they did the
update said you can destroy it i'm
assuming yeah it just has hit points you
could do whatever you want sure
but obviously if you're on the right
side of it it'll
if you if someone if you're an enemy
throws an amp shield and you shoot it
from the right side will it amp your
bullets if it's not your shield i've
never tried it before they're usually
not there long enough yeah i wonder um
i'm probably gonna have to call it
unless you want to keep playing i'm
gonna have to call it personally it's
three o'clock
um yeah i'm gonna do
one more okay uh i want to use north
star a little bit longer but yeah
unfortunately i have to bounce but yeah
of course we're happy everybody in the
chat i'll see you later see i'm gonna go
watch for my desk while i get some stuff
done cool cool
i will do my best to answer questions in
the chat while playing
it's tough but i'll do my best
um
thanks for watching guys
uh let's do one more here
i'm gonna use northstar apologies for
not getting the execution i'm just not
very good at legion and i tend to flock
to northstar
but
let's get right to it
all right new skin
okay
yeah if you guys want to see anything
else let me know in the
chat
other than that
hopefully we'll get in a match
let's see here
threat optics
legit
deal those snipers
we have a basement
i live in my basement says
devil prada and white
cool
north star prime you got it oh cool last
time standing oh i should change this
there's no point in using this
here we go
should i go for a battery
let's do it
it's always a risky move
where are you going baby get back here
come to me
here we go no kind of left
i see you
oh yeah
you get my
footing first oh
yeah you are you're pursuing i like it
oh another guy here
who's shooting now these guys are
flanking aren't they
yeah they are
flat core let's do it
yeah
ah
come here
oh get him away get my way
oh come here
yeah
that punch
oh is my uh
cluster missile that come
david crowley says
prime north star doe i agree super hot
north star prime reminds me of something
i don't know if it's like gundam
but it's not that
it's like that sleek
design is something i can't put my
finger on it
all right should i go for
look at these butt heads
ronin
coming in
woozy willy my nemesis
uh no he went for the battery get back
in
cool i just want to see the
outside of my titan
oh yeah oh yeah
where you going ronin
oh oh man look at that lag damn
all right let's worry about this north
star i love north star right over the
wall
no reason to do that no one there oh
here we go
yeah yeah yeah yeah
where'd you go woozy
dead
damn where'd he go that's good cover
that's
weird
silly willy i agree let's
do this
of course there's no need since we're
crushing it
god that skin
oh cool yeah i like this combo here
trail mixes have for like a execution
have a holo pilot execution from the
front where you send a holo pilot behind
them then they turn around and you kill
them i love it
i love it that's a good one
awol though i don't know i don't know
what you could do with awol
maybe you could like kick them down
throw down the wall and then just unload
like an lmg into them i don't know
has soon says never got good at sword
fighting
assuming you're talking about ronin i
agree i'm i'm not very good with ronan
ronin and legion i think are like
are the two that haven't they're just
they get so much going on as far as like
cooldowns and when
to use them like ion you're generally
pretty safe because it's more of a
simple titan but yeah like ronin's just
got such precious health
willie
nope
not to a good start
a hit
there's another
who are you where are you
christ
smoke
yeah i saw your missile
oh he's doing it
trees
he's got one shot on me
oh
saves my ass
thank you equinox
yeah do it
oh i got him
oh that's funny you didn't see it you
hear it though
that's funny
all right should i play to 330
or should i do one more
if enough people want me to play i'll
play maybe two more i'll play two more
that's probably 3 30.
all right what do we got here
i do like gun runner
you want that tax kill though
hat chat
thanks phil
should i buy ah
considering buying um the camera wasn't
that interesting i don't know if i'd do
it
regen regen
[Music]
[Laughter]
regen
should i really
yeah why not
let's do it
regen region
years of battle have taken their toll
we can regenerate you at a cost your
body can be restored but much of your
memory and experience will be lost
these will have to
earn all over again in fact
when you awaken you will respond as the
next generation pilot would you like to
go
to the next gen
let's do it
in the chat who's got the highest gen
no lying
how does the map play with
titans good question well that's
definitely the most
uh
we've been doing today uh
it's all right i don't know i mean
earlier if uh you're tuning in now i got
stuck with legion in a i called down
legion in an area that was like fenced
off and i couldn't get out luckily i had
um
the extra dash for legion and was able
to get out but
that was not cool
for heftier titans like scorch
and legion i don't think you can get out
of there
uh hopefully they can address that by i
don't know opening up the wall a little
more
gen 7 gen 9 gen 10
nice
1050.
is there max gen
oh there is a
yeah there's a cap okay i figured
oh great
i'm now looking at all my
loadouts are changed
god this is such a chore
excuse me i prepped
actually to start a game jesus
uh
yeah let's hope
for something that's not last time
standing
um
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
low profile
mm-hmm
and
let's
get that new gun
i do like this gun i mean
it r201
is good
i mean this is
so it's factory it's just it's got scope
on it
all right
powders
i want you shotgun on this map
i got it
any more game audio
yes
yeah
yeah
nope
i do like this map well
uh
this falls as far as wall running
like if i can get way more creative and
like juke people out more
which is very fun with a
i hired the shotgun pilot that's for
sure
oh come on
oh he's there oh yeah come on inside
pulling away turn it around
oh
oh i'm getting a lot of lag
it's not well i guess it was me there
jesus
that's unlike us
oh this is rough
oh can i just do this
huh forgot about that oh perfect
oh dang i should have been sooner
so i got awarded something but i didn't
really show
up this feels
a little glitchy today
damn
it um do i like
automatic shotguns or shotguns uh well
this game doesn't really have enough is
this auto yeah i guess it is auto i
never use it like that so i guess um
the massive is too slow for me
um
it's got range which i think is is nice
but uh
when it comes down to it like like
having the speed of like pulling off
like a double kill
um
but that's just me
i don't know if you guys like the mass
stuff more
show them what you've got
shoot
nice
rainbow cheese
it's pretty good name
there's a guy with my head no
ah i that's the second time i've done
that sometimes the windows get tricky
you can't see him
sometimes so you just like wall run
right into him wow that's kind of rough
there
nope
rainbow cheese
my favorite prime titan so far um
i would say northstar so far it's pretty
awesome you know it's the executions you
got to consider as well i think north
star has a real awesome one i think my
second favorite would
be
uh scorch i think scorches prime
execution is awesome it's like two
punches and then that core ability move
is so badass
oh
damn
sniping with a revolver always
entertaining
yeah
that was better at it i don't really do
that often yeah there you go rainbow
cheese
yin
i'm yang too far ahead
or too far behind excuse me
dang it
sorry for yelling
are there any female titans um
yeah it's it's split down the middle um
you know they're essentially just robots
so they don't really have any like
obvious indications uh other than the
voices
over yet
damn
why do i use the cloak
um
honestly i have a bad habit and it's
cloak eva shotgun
it's just my favorite thing in this game
um
i generally like that in most shooters
but
i don't know there's i think i think why
i like it so much is that you can bridge
gaps with the cloak
um
because obviously you're sitting duck
with shotgun on the in the open
so uh you want to be you know next to
any kind of obstacle or indoors even um
so if needed i can um you know engage it
and like hop on the rooftops for a
moment
what's up goop mike uh had to leave a
little early and i'm gonna do
uh one more match
thank you guys for sticking around
if there's anything else you'd like to
see
um we've shown most things the only
other thing i haven't shown is uh
the
execution for prime or legion prime i'm
not very good with legion i can try it
if you'd really like me to do that but
otherwise
yeah let me know
if the chat really wants it i'll do it
sweet last match yeah goob you're a
little late sorry bud
this is uh titanfall 2 topher
my favorite game of 2016.
real fun
and we're in attrition perfect way to go
out i like it
oh you got it north star primes
execution
i will do my best i hate i'm sorry i'm
pending anyone i do not like
this fight sarah
dynamics which what's your guys's
favorite uh
faction i think it's for me it's vision
dynamics it's just like
so something so badass about it
it's like there's no emotion just like
you are dominating pilot
just love that
here we go
oh yeah where you going up
okay
i thought there's a guy crap bad move
don't move
all right
wow we are not doing good are we
christ see right here i should
have my cloak ready
cloak me
there we go there we go okay
nope nope nope nope wait wait wait wait
wait
wait just give me a second give me a sec
hold on hold on
hold on
flying
i see you
apex predators i'm into it
famous pronounced vision
oh
oh no i don't my pistol oh i blew it
[ __ ]
they're hitting us
but we can still win this thing all
right i'll give you a kill shoot i can
do it
yeah there's your kill streak
behind us
a little flag again
go out like this
oh boy
whoa where oh of course
it's a good move
you don't see me
what oh my loadout for north star isn't
oh my god i forgot because i regen
christ
excessive
i'm kind of
cornered here
nope let's get out
all right that'll work
kind of
comfortable
he's trying to do the execution there oh
i see
here we go
where's everyone
cool
kept thinking i was ion
what
man there's much
lag oh here we go
does he know what i'm trying to do
let's find out
oh good move
damn
let's see if he likes this
into it
you are dominating
sorry for being loud
don't lose hope
damn
oh i don't have the other one selected
shoot i forgot to change all my load act
regening was
a little
rough
i should have changed my loadouts
[Music]
oh still got one more
nope
yes
bob jones i would love to play all day
and night but uh time for me to wrap
this up uh i think that's a good enough
ending
um
thank you guys so much for uh watching
uh time fall too
uh i would say ultimately
i think there's some
glitches here and there lag wasn't too
great let's hope servers get uh up to
speed
uh the nose art i would i hope that some
of these ui things uh if they are
just that like um
you know like
it'd be a shame if basically there's
just six nose arts between
uh same nose arts for each titan that'd
be kind of a bummer so let's hope that
uh
i don't know maybe we'll see if uh it's
ui things or if that's the update
regardless uh north star prime pretty
cool i'm into it
that's about it thank you guys for
watching have a great rest of the week
see you later
bye
you